ich habe die tür vergessen hallo mein
name ist luca herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen serie ich habe mir gedacht
habe ich noch nicht genug serien auf
meinem kanal habe starte ich doch
einfach mal ein neuer und zwar diese
serie die sims 4
diese freuen sich glaube ich alle sogar
schon die klicken einfach mal auf play
und chips mit dem wasser was ist ich
habe auf jeden fall schon mal die stimme
von luke herausgefunden und zwar just
die hier genau so rede ich auch ein
jordanier ihn einfach mal luca trottel
und dann machen wir jetzt einfach mal
die komplette familie trottel wir müssen
hier vorne jetzt das bestreben wählen
stunden habe ich jetzt endlich mal den
perfekten luca ihn gekriegt das gesicht
sieht auf jeden fall so ein bisschen aus
wie ich der körper soll auf jeden fall
immer rum ich glaube jeder der film
spielt wird entweder willow creek oder
newcrest irgendwie nehmen weil es
einfach richtig schön ist aber ich
glaube ich im oasis brings deutschen
monat täglich dem wie das hat die
videospiel fähigkeit erworben luca kann
seine computer fähigkeit an computern
tablets motion gaming ausrüstungen und
sogar am telefon weiter verbessern
bitte was okay wir haben jetzt hier auf
jeden fall ein wundervolles alte die
grafik ist wir haben hier das grundstück
zusammen mit unseren nachbarn kommen die
besucher war einfach mal ihr könnt mir
unzählige tipps in die kommentare
schreiben ich habe ultrabook darauf
dieses let's play zu machen das soll
jetzt nicht so typisch werden dass ich
mich wirklich in die reihen versetzte
sondern mehr so guckt euch allein diesen
typen hier schon an das ist doch dass
das lokal wo was was wo wird doch mit
mir ich werde mich dann jetzt mal damit
beschäftigen hier irgendwie ein harten
luca war er beobachtet da hinten jetzt
einen stein fun fact ich habe mir bisher
kein einziges tutorial angeschaut und
versuche jetzt irgendwie ein haus zu
bauen das kann was werden ich lüge
gerade nicht in der rosat gerade bei 25
minuten und hat mich die ganze zeit
einfach nur damit beschäftigt dieses
haus hier zu bauen
ich gebe euch jetzt eine kleine tour
das hier ist das badezimmer dass ich
habe die tür vergessen also das hier ist
quasi das haus hier ist der eingang ich
habe als eingangstür sonne toilettentür
gewählt dann kommen wir jetzt mal zu den
wichtigsten sachen und zwar habe ich
hier ganz normal das bett also wenn man
reingeht dass man direkt ins bett
steigen kann und wenn man auf die
toilette muss hat man dann direkt eine
toilette daneben dann habe ich auch
direkt hier eine grüne tonne hingestellt
einfach dafür wenn ich im müll habt dass
sich die nach hinten schmerzen kamen und
dann ist der in der in der in der dann
kommen wir zudem auf dass ich am aller
stolz system bin und zwar sich ein
kleines horn das einhorn lama hier vorne
haben wir dann auch noch martin monster
bob und babsi beiden das sind die sind
das ist das ist wenn ich schlafe dass
ich dann dass sie glaube ich aus über 50
freddys dann soll ich das eigentlich
mehr zocken dann habe ich natürlich hier
den wänden deko von dinosauriern
dinosauriern und meiner lieblingsserie
die hexen leute weg in slate mit kann
doch auch wieder nicht sein denn er
macht hier einmal kurz zurück zu dann
hat lukas schon wieder ab wo ist der
einfachen buch dieser facebook die
debatte live ins netz aber wir machen
weiter mit und wer ist diese person in
unserem haus luca steht da hinten
irgendwo am arsch der welt und ließen
buch halb nackt und hier ist eine und
jeder kann und natürlich kinder regal wo
das offen
ja da kann natürlich jeder rein das
stimmt natürlich jedenfalls habe ich
dann hier noch ein paar teppich hier
hingelegt auch von dinosauriern
natürlich dann habe ich den fernseher
hingestellt und mit dem sofa ich wusste
aber nicht wie ich die sachen drehe
deswegen muss man sich jetzt hier neben
mark wie das monster auf den boden
setzen und fernsehen zu schauen hier
vorne habe ich eine ganz schlichte küche
einfach hingestellt die habe ich mir so
einfach gekauft und hier halt das ganz
normale badezimmer hier halt ein cooler
spiegel und hier habe ich einen
hochzeitskarten falls ich mal heiraten
will
meine küche ist einfach offen ich wusste
jetzt nicht wie ich mir anders helfen
soll deswegen hab ich da jetzt einfach
eine wand umgebaut so dass man da quasi
nicht mehr rein kann und zwar so nicht
schwarz kannst du dich niemals verpissen
luca kommt jetzt hier vorne gerade
angelaufen weil er sich jetzt dem
nachbarn vorstellen will luca was hast
du denn getan ist ja kein wunder wenn du
da mitten in der pampa auf einmal ein
buch liest luca du hast gar nicht
schwarz verpasst wir müssen auf jeden
fall erst mit johnny schwarz nein
wo ist johnny schwarzen dem linke geht
beney vom juca trottel den namen müssen
wir definitiv firma bearbeiten
irgendwann alter so sieht's aus als
müsste von bob und babsi beobachtet
werden so freunde willkommen zu einer
neuen folge kochen mit luca trottel der
macht heute nämlich hamburger kuchen
das macht er ganz toll hier die küche
brennt das war klar johnny hilft mir
kommen kommen komm rein ja jakunin ich
hoffe wenigstens dass unser hamburger
kuchen irgendwie schmeckt ich guck mal
einfach wie der kommt luca ist mal und
wie schmeckt er johnny das ist mein ich
mag giardini so ganz normale
unterhaltung zwischen luca und johnny
die beiden luca toni wir beiden gehen
jetzt mal irgendwohin luca bestehen
an dieser stelle beende ich das video